So welcome back everybody.
It's probably, uh,
will take a while to wrestle your brains
back to what we were talking about
before the break. Um, and I'll, I'll,
I'll do my best to help in that endeavor.
And um,
we're talking,
we're really finishing up the
first two thirds of the course.
Well by talking about John Rawls.
Um,
a very
interesting figure and phenomenon
in modern political philosophy.
We finish it up the first two thirds
of the course in the sense that,
um,
this is the third enlightenment tradition.
We're talking about the first two having
been utilitarianism and Marxism and
after we finished with the roles,
we're going to talk about the Anti
Enlightenment tradition and then the
democratic traditions.
Um,
so roles is an odd figure in some ways.
if,
if I had been here or if my predecessor
from a prior generation had been here,
I teach teaching a course like
this in the 1950s or early 1960s.
And somebody had speculated that maybe
are very major figure would emerge in
American political philosophy.
There would've been a lot of skepticism
and they would have been even more
skepticism if somebody had said and
they would have been a theorist of the
social contract.
And I think that would have been
two reasons for that skepticism.
One is that political philosophy
was really not thought to
be a particularly important
area of philosophy of
academic philosophy in
the 1950s and 1960s,
the people who,
who were sort of seen as the cutting edge
in philosophy were doing philosophy of
language, logic, epistemology,
metaphysics and political philosophy was
sort of weighed down on the totem pole.
Uh,
it was a subdivision of ethics and sort
of ethics for many people if you like.
Um,
and the notion that anybody in philosophy
who did political philosophy would
turn out to be a major figure would
have attracted a lot of skepticism among
academic philosophers.
And yet John Roles,
I think today, and if you, if you polled,
if you went around the most prestigious
philosophy departments in the world,
not just in the English
speaking world today and said,
who was the most important philosopher
of the last third of the 20th century?
Not Political Philosophy,
just philosopher.
MMM.
And you and you asked that question of
okay,
people in major philosophy departments
around the world roles would be cited
more than any other person.
Yeah.
That, any doubt about it. I
don't have any doubt about it.
He'd decided more than any other person.
MMM.
So that's one reason people would have
been skeptical that they just didn't
think political philosophy
is that important and,
and this sort of serious heavyweights
in phosphene did other things.
But then I think the second reason people
would have been skeptical is that a
theorist of the social contract and
everybody knew that the social contract,
which is you all know has been
around in its modern form,
at least since the 17th century. Everybody
knew it had these two huge problems.
One was that it didn't have,
um,
okay,
any grounding in natural
law that people accepted.
And the second was it never
was a social contract.
We now know from 150 years of anthropology
than ever was a social contract.
Aristotle was closer to being accurate
when he sort of treated human beings as
inherently political.
There was never a pre political condition.
MMM.
And as you now know,
because we've studied Robert Nozick MMM.
The revival of the social
contract tradition answered
both those questions first
by replacing natural law with
some version of a manual cons,
ethics. So ethic, uh,
con becomes the place
holder for natural law.
And on the other hand,
working with hypothetical contracts
rather than actual contracts.
The asking the question,
what would people agree to?
Not what did people agreed to,
uh,
under certain specified conditions.
But neither of those ideas
was central to Nozick.
I was invented by Nozick rare that both
of those ideas were invented by roles
and Nozick was one of many
people who reacted to roles.
I had pedagogical reasons for
dealing with Nozick first,
namely that his argument, it goes,
grows so directly out of locks.
But if this was a course in the history
of 20th century political philosophy,
of course we would have done roles first.
And it's really important to say this
because no one knows x book would never
have been written.
But for roles.
And I think that one measure of the
importance of roles is that there are
probably 50 bucks and I don't know how
many articles that would never have been
written, but for roles you can go out
and find roles as book in the library,
uh, and you'll find it on
the shelf next to the book.
Just books listing the
citations to roles as buck.
And so that's a very interesting fact.
It's also an interesting fact because
roles is not a great in the sense that we
think of as Hobbes, Locke or male ow, ow,
Dewey who we don't read in this course
as great in the sense that he does.
Most of those people had a view of
the world that range right across all
domains of knowledge. So if
you read, you know, locked,
he had a philosophy and a view of,
of knowledge of you have language of
your theology, of your politics, uh,
a view of everything.
Mel had a theory of science.
He had a mathematical theory. He had, um,
theories of meaning. He had, um, uh,
an epistemology and he had a theory
of politics. Dewey, same story.
There's a,
there's a whole,
there's a whole world view that's worked
out in every what we today think of as
disciplines,
but for most of the tradition,
we're not divided up in the
way we divide things up today,
but they have the people we tend to call
greats had a view that ranges across
the whole range, the whole, um,
gamut of knowledge,
uh,
roles that didn't do that.
He doesn't have a metaphysics,
he doesn't have a pest homology,
doesn't have a theory of science.
He doesn't have a theory of language.
He only wrote this book. Uh,
basically you wrote some articles
which led up to the book and then some,
some things that follow out of the book,
but basically his book,
the theory of Justice
is it, um, and so he's,
he's not a great in that sense
of the greats of the tradition,
but he certainly has more intellectual
staying power than anyone.
Any con contemporary in a broad sense
of the word that you've read in this
course or we'll read in this course.
People will still be reading
roles long after, um,
uh, people like me have been
forgotten about. So, um,
in that sense it's a really
important figure and uh,
he's a really important figure,
um,
also in the sense that even if
you don't like his arguments,
even if you've completely
unpersuaded by all of his arguments,
you have to come to grips
with them. Uh, I don't,
I'm not in sympathy with any
of his major arguments. Um,
but he's, he's not, you cannot work in
this field and not deal with John Rolls.
That's how important he is and
he's going to be for a long time.
So that's just by way of background,
um,
and letting you know
what you're dealing with.
One other thing I'd say about a theory
of justice is it is not a well written
book. It's not badly written
in the sense that it's unclear.
Any given paragraph is clear enough.
If you sit down and figure
out what the jargon means,
it's not a hard and
that in the sense that,
um,
uh,
say the technical sides of,
of, of marks or parade or hard,
but it's not captivating writing.
You need a chair with a hard back to
read this book and there's a reason for
that. The reason is that although
the book was published in 1971,
mmm,
roles actually came up with the main
ideas in the 1960s in a couple of articles
and most famous of which was
called justices fairness.
And he circulated these
articles in the profession,
in the philosophy profession and he kept
getting criticisms and he eventually
had a book manuscript and he circulated
the book manuscript and he kept getting
criticisms and every time
somebody sent him a criticism,
he added three paragraphs
to address the criticism.
This is not the way to write a book
if you want it to be captivating.
So it's got this kind of almost plodding
quality that's a sort of at variance
with the, the hype I just
gave you about his importance,
but it's to do with the composition
of the book. Uh, I mean the actual,
oh, there's 10 years of endlessly
fiddling with this manuscript.
Uh,
and I should should also say that he,
he eventually did a second edition
of the book later in his life.
MMM.
Which is a substantial rewrite of
it from the first edition. So he,
he was somebody who couldn't, who
couldn't stop fiddly. Um, and it's not a,
it's not a trait to which I would,
I would commend to you,
but in any event, there
it is. So, and it's,
it's any long and if not plotting,
certainly ponderous a buck.
And My, my goal in the,
in these lectures about roles is to try
and pull out the main ideas for you.
And in particularly the main
enduring ideas, because Raul's,
like everybody else,
we've read as an architect,
tonic theorist fails. The,
the pieces don't add up there.
Big logical holes in the big structure.
Um,
so if you want it to be the
silver bullet or the final word,
it's not going to happen.
Nonetheless,
there are very important in
during insights, uh, questions,
roles put on the table,
which have not gone away.
And I'm not going to go away for
anybody who wants to think about the
fundamentals of political association.
So,
um,
okay,
what are these ideas?
Well, they, they get,
I think Mick stop to some extent or hidden
or obscured or it's made to seem more
complicated than they should be,
partly because of the
architecture of his theory,
partly because of the way
he does the exposition.
He has the story about
the original position,
which is his version of the social con,
the hypothetical social contract.
And,
and let me just give you the intuition,
but I want to preface it by saying it's
actually not important to his theory.
It's really an expository device
because what he does is he structures a
hypothetical choice and then he gives
you a certain kinds of information to get
you to choose a certain outcome.
So unless the outcome is
itself independently desirable,
um,
the fact that this,
this thought experiment leads
to it is of no interest.
Let me give you an example
before we get into roles,
which is one that he himself Gibbs,
and this is the,
I'm not sure if it seemed one of the
excerpts you read or not, but this is a,
an observation that has been
around long before royal. She says,
what is the fair way to cut a
cake? Is this, you read anybody?
What's a fair way to cut a cake?
Yeah,
probably not if nobody,
I'm sure you spent your spring
break wading through roles. Yeah,
correct.
So you give the,
the person with a knife gets the
last slice and what will they do?
Okay.
So if you say, well, how
would they divide it?
Yeah. If you think so. So what are
the, are two assumptions there?
Okay. You say, what's the fair
way to cut a cake? The answer,
the fair way to cut a cake is to give the,
the,
the person with the knife gets
the last slice. What will they do?
They will divide it equally. Right?
That's how the person or the last,
the knife gets a biggest possible slice.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Anyone think that's not the fair
way to cut a cake? Do it anyway.
Okay. Well there are two assumptions
there that are worth bringing to the fore.
Just just for, um, pup.
Is that what I'm going to say
to you about roles in a minute?
One is that we think dividing
the cake equally is the right
is, you know, we, we're,
we've devised a system where the
case can you get equally divided,
right? But do it, do we think it should
be equally divided? What if we, it,
what if I added other
information? Like, uh,
one of the people in the room was starving
and hadn't eaten for three days or
one was a diabetic or,
right.
And we could add other information which
would make you one to do you want to
get an equal division?
Right?
So the cake cutting example doesn't
show you that equality is a good thing.
It presumes that you've already decided
equality is a good thing and you want to
get the person to choose equality.
Right.
Okay.
Then the other thing that it,
it is,
it assumes is that people are gonna
behave self interestedly, right? When we,
when we give the person the knife
and say divided however you like,
you get the last slice,
we're assuming that she or he will behave,
be wanting to get the biggest
possible slice. So we've uh,
immediately we've got two assumptions
built into their one that equality is a
good thing. That's the result
we actually do want to get.
And secondly that people are going
to behave in a self interested way,
right? Which isn't to say
they're bad assumptions,
but it's to note that they
are assumptions. Okay.
Now rolls as original position
has the same structures,
the cake cutting fee for
both of those reasons.
He has a distributed outcome
that he wants to convince you is,
is a good thing and
he's going to create a,
a hypothetical choice situation
that will lead you to it,
right?
But that doesn't itself establish
that it is a good thing.
You have to have some other argument to
convince you that it is a good thing.
And I'll tell you what that argument is,
but it's completely independent of this
expository expository device that's
modeled on the cake cutting.
So the expository device that's model
on the cake cutting goes like this.
It says,
imagine,
imagine you had to design a social order,
a society
and it co which include in
a broader sense of the word,
it will include an economic system,
a political system and so on.
Okay.
And you didn't know
whether you were going to turn out
to be ritual poor male or female,
what you are going to be, whether
you're going to be an athlete or a nerd.
Um, you didn't have any particular
information about yourself.
Do you watch your, where are you
going to have an Iq or low Iq musical?
Not Musical. I had good
athlete, a bad athlete, nothing.
You didn't have that kind of
information about yourself.
Yeah.
Which doesn't mean that there,
there could be people who didn't
have those characteristics, right?
It's just like say you have to design
the rules of chess and you didn't know
whether or not you're going to be good
at using bishop better using our bishop.
Then, but then using a night, but
yet to agree on certain rules. Okay.
So the rules for designing society,
you're going to choose while being
ignorant of what he calls particular facts
about your circumstances.
You're gonna know only
certain pretty general things.
Like he says,
it's a world of moderate scarcity.
So it,
it's not super abundance,
which is a good thing cause we found
out when we studied Marx that there's no
coherent idea of super
abundant, moderate scas. The,
it's not very,
it's not a developing country.
What we think of today. Is it the
third world or developing country?
It's basically principals for
countries of the sort we live in.
Okay. So, um,
moderate scarcity and we're gonna assume
certain basic when he calls laws of
psychology and economics.
And I think that people largely behave
self interestedly is the most important
of those. Um, but beyond that,
you're not going to have particular
knowledge about yourself and your
circumstances in particular,
sorry to use particular into conflicting
ways. But in Perth in particular,
you're not going to have the kind of
knowledge that would allow you to buy us
things in your own direction so that if
you knew you were going to turn out to
be female, you could, you know,
say women should earn
twice as much as men,
but you're not going to know whether
you're going to turn out to be female or
male.
So the kind of knowledge you're going to
be denied is the kind of knowledge that
would let you buy us
things in your own favor.
Okay.
So that's the sense in which
he's trying to be a contrarian.
He calls his principles procedural
expressions of the categorical imperative.
There's a mouthful for you on the
first day back from spring break.
We know what the categorical
imperative is, right? It's, it's, um,
it's the imperative to choose things that
are universalize about things that you
would, well, regardless of the
consequences. So thanks. You would,
well, from every conceivable standpoint
and what roles is trying to do,
I says these a procedural expression
of it. What he's trying to do is say,
well,
if you don't have knowledge of where,
which kind of person you're going to
turn out to be in terms of rich or poor
male or female or black or white or
Hispanic or some other ethnic group or a
religious of some sort, or as atheist,
you don't know any of those things.
You're going to have to think
about what are the social,
what are the best social rules for people
regardless of who they turn out to be.
And that's the sense in which he wants
to think of himself as a content.
So where's for nosy could sort
of just a slogan for Rawls.
It's really built into the
structure of his argument.
Okay.
And the idea of the original position
is to force us even while recognizing
where self interested to force us
to think about society as a whole,
to think about what,
what,
what would be desirable regardless
of who you turned out to be.
Okay.
And so then his eye,
the basic way, the book,
if you had time to read the whole book,
the Basic Way the book proceeds is he
starts out with this complete veil of
ignorance and tries to get
to get you to agree with him
and this sense, it's not even really a
social contract. He's, he's not saying,
you know, would you agree with one
another? What he wants to say is,
will you the reader agree with me,
John Rawls,
that any rational church and would choose
the principles that I'm arguing for.
In that sense,
he's actually,
yeah,
we can't do it in this course
because we did an read Hobbs.
He's actually more like Hobbes.
Then he is like lock because you know,
for hubs the social contract isn't a
legitimate because anybody made it,
but because it must be
rational to make it,
any rational person says Hobbs would
agree to give up their freedom to an
absolute sovereign because anything else
needs to civil war in is just madness.
So it's,
it's an,
it's a property of rationality
for Hobbs that people were,
we'll accept the authority
of the sovereign. There isn't
really a contract. Well,
Rawls is more like hubs on
that point. He's, he's saying,
I want to pee.
I John Rawls want to persuade you,
the reader that any rational person would
choose my principles of justice over
the going alternatives
because his style of thinking,
okay,
people go on and on about roles being
abstract and an ideal theorist and head in
the clouds. But actually his actual way
of proceeding is, isn't that it's very,
it's comparative.
Basically what he does is he says,
well, what are the going
alternatives? There's utilitarianism.
There's, there are other ones
you haven't read in the score.
So it's this perfectionism,
which is what he thinks of in Aristotle.
There's Marxism.
Um,
I want to show you that my principal
does better than the going alternatives
from the perspective of being
behind this veil of ignorance.
If somebody else comes along with another
principal and shows that it does even
better than mine,
then I would give it up.
So his basic mode of
reasoning is comparative.
Okay.
And
what, so what he does is he as
a general principle of justice,
which he wants to persuade you off first
from behind this veil of ignorance and
then more specific applications of it.
Um,
he ends up coming up with two principles
of justice that are the applications,
which are really three principles.
So I'll go through them with you,
but then more if you win more
and more into the book he gets,
he keeps adding information and lets you
design more specific institutions and
so on. Always with the caveat that
as you get more information later,
you can't go back and undo
choices that you made earlier.
Right.
So it's sort of like,
I don't know if you've been around long
enough to ever see Congress go through a
base closing exercise for the military,
um,
where they,
they realize that there's going to be
special pleading from every can, you know,
say say they're going to get
rid of 30 military basis. Um,
every congressional district that has a
base in it is going to have good reasons
why yes,
we should get rid of 30 basis,
but not the one in our district.
Right.
We Know wanna stop making
submarines in Groton,
right? Whatever it is. And so
what they do is they get an, they,
they get, they create a commission, um,
that agrees on the base closing nationwide
and they have to vote up or down on
the entire package and then they can start
undoing it later so that the just has
a kind of structure of a base closing
commission that as the veil of ignorance
starts to be lifted, you know,
and then you discover, well,
actually I turned out to
be female rather than male.
I can't then say,
oh,
well women should get some
certain particular kind of
advantage. Right. So that,
that's the way the book proceeds.
Now.
Um,
I think
one other reason I should tell you about,
oh,
actually two reasons I should tell you
about concerning why this book had such a
big impact,
why this book has had the
staying power that it's had.
One is,
it's really very much a book of the
1960s and seventies where there was just
some extent,
a crisis of confidence about liberal
democratic institutions born of the
student's movement and this,
the Vietnam War and
everything that went with it.
That is to say,
uh,
there was a generation of people who
thought we needed to have critical
standards for evaluating
government and utilitarianism,
which was the main alternative around,
didn't seem to provide them.
And roles came up with this notion that
we could come up with an independent
standard for judging
actually existing political systems and
then use it to see how they measure up.
I wouldn't have to be rooted in natural
law and all the problems that went with
it and was going to be rooted
in this universal content ideal.
And it would give us a principles by
which we could evaluate not only what our
government does,
but other governments.
So I think it was just some extent kind
of thirst for criteria that that was
characteristic of that era that,
um,
gave rolls his staying power.
But then I think the other reason,
the other reason
that Rawls has had
staying power was that he
change the subject that people who had
been squabbling about utilitarianism for
150 years had been arguing about
because, and again, this is,
you know, this now because of
the first half of this semester,
but utilitarianism had basically been
mmm.
Struggling between two variants.
One which we think often the
terminology of this course as classical
utilitarianism we might call objectivist,
where you make strong
interpersonal judgments of utility.
And the problem with that as we saw is,
and as Raul says repeatedly in his book,
it doesn't take seriously the
differences among persons.
You could see this in the
utility monster example.
You could see this in the,
um,
the problems that we have with
the bag lady and Donald Trump.
You can see this in problems
with the disabled that,
that if you don't allow
interpersonal, I, I'm sorry,
if you do allow interpersonal
judgments of utility,
you can do draconian things in
the name of maximizing utility.
But if you, if you say, no,
we're not going to do that,
and you make the neoclassical move and
use then say we cannot even allow that.
Taking a nickel from Trump and giving it
to the bag lady necessarily leads to an
increase in social utility,
then you seem to have the
opposite problem. So the,
the objectivist problem is it allows,
uh,
people to be used in the
name of maximizing utility.
The subjectivist version,
the neoclassical version doesn't seem
to allow any interpersonal judgments of
utility, both a deeply
morally unsatisfying. And so,
and the proponents of each one 10
to make the case for their view,
mainly by pointing to the
demerits of the other view. Right?
And they're both right.
Both of these views have serious demerits.
And so part of what roles does
is he changes the subject.
He changes the subject,
and he changes it in an interesting way.
He says,
luck.
Okay.
The truth is we should be objectivist
about some things and subjectivist about
other things. And what does he
mean by this? He says, luck.
Okay.
People are substantially alike about
on some dimensions and unalike on other
dimensions. There's deep
pluralism of values. Yes,
but you know we basically have the same
needs, the same physiology, the same.
We tend, we tend to need
the same kinds of resources.
So let's focus on resources
rather than on utility.
Let's focus on some basic resources that
everybody needs regardless of whether
they're going to be intellectuals or
artists or sportsman or sportswomen or
politicians.
There's still,
there's certain things you're going
to need more of rather than less off.
Other things being equal
sort of instrumental goods.
You could think of them as
well and let's focus on that.
And especially in political.
Yeah,
political theory.
Those are a good thing to focus on
because after all we're talking about what
the state might know might not
do and the state, as we all know,
you know,
acts with blunt instruments.
This idea of the government sort of
putting a utility amateur and the people's
tongues to find out what their utility is.
That's not it.
It's, it's apart from being
technically problematic.
It's know nobody wants that.
It's morally undesirable.
So you have to think about just the
state as something that action with blunt
instruments.
And you can only really,
if you want to a realistic
political theory,
you should focus on some basic resources
in the society that the state could
have some impact on.
So instead of various
competing definitions of
utility or welfare role says
let's change the subject
to talking about resources,
um, that, uh,
have the quality a that the things
that we could really imagine the state
dealing with and be that an instrumentally
valuable to people no matter what
they turn out to one in life.
So that,
that's a second reason he was
important. He, she, of course,
academics are not comfortable
unless they create an ism word.
So the ism word is resources and roles.
I should,
as in resources and it stops talking about
welfarism stops talking about utility
or welfare or the subjective
experiences that people get,
um, but rather the resources
that they have at their disposal.
So that's a second reason I think he's
had his views have had a lot of staying
power.
People who don't like his particular
resources theory have nonetheless embraced
other resources. Theories. Again,
sort of in the wake of
roles, if you like. Okay,
so what is the basic idea?
What is the basic principle?
Okay,
it's,
it's his general conception of justice,
which he says all social values
by which he means resources.
As I've just said it to you now,
and it's going to say that they're three
while he is,
he talks about liberty's opportunities,
income and wealth, which he
treats together. So that's three,
and then a fourth one.
The social bases of self respect.
I'll come back to all of that in minute.
I'd have been distributed equally unless
an unequal distribution or any of any
of all of these values is
to everybody's advantage.
That is the basic idea.
All social values by which he means
resources should be distributed equally
unless an unequal distribution
benefits everyone.
That is the first and most general
formulation of his principal.
So let me just back up a little bit.
Okay.
I'll go through liberties, opportunities,
income, and wealth in more detail.
Starting in a minute,
I'm just gonna mention this.
Social bases for self-respect briefly and
then not talk about it anymore because
of time limitations.
And because rolls himself never
says anything much about them.
Uh,
yeah.
And what he has to say.
I don't think it's very coherent.
So we'll just forget about the
social bases of self respect, um,
for the moment.
Maybe come back to them later.
But so here's the thing ought to be
distributed equally unless an unequal
distribution works to
everybody's advantage.
Now you might say why,
right?
That's the first question,
It's the first question you ask and
roles is not going to give you a straight
answer. He's not. There's not a, because
for the reason I said to, Oh yeah, his
reasoning is comparative. So he says,
well you could, you could say
this is one candidate principal,
you bring another candidate principal,
like say utilitarianism.
And we'll look at both from behind the
veil of ignorance and see which makes
more sense to beck.
Okay.
So that's the sense in which he has
a comparative advantage argument,
not a knockdown,
philosophical demonstration from first
principles that this must follow.
So,
while I do want to say that he thinks it
follows from the nature of reason that
you would make this choice,
it's only a comparative
choice and somebody could
come along with something else
and,
um,
convince you that it does better than
his principal. And then he'd have to, uh,
except that,
so,
okay.
What he does, and this is his
resources. I mean action is he,
he defines these primary goods.
Primary goods are these instrumental
goods, these things you would,
other things being equal rather
have more of than less off.
Uh, and the, the three we're
going to focus on our liberties,
opportunities and income and wealth.
And I'm gonna we'll probably only
manage to deal with liberty's today,
but it'll give you a flavor
of how his reasoning works.
So what our liberties,
well,
that pretty much the sort of thing in
the bill of rights and the American bill
of rights, freedom of speech, freedom
of religion, freedom of association.
MMM.
Freedom actually did participate in
democratic politics is one that he talks
about. Um, and he's,
his principle for the
distribution of liberties is,
I just put it up there.
He says
each person has to have an equal right
to the most extensive system of total
extensive time. I told you
this ponderous, extensive,
total system of liberties compatible
with a similar system of liberty for all.
It sounds like a lot of words,
not saying very much.
So let me show you why it says more than
it might appear to say at first sight.
Let's take the example
of religious freedom.
So
okay,
let's say, well, should we
have an established religion?
How can we reason about this
from behind the valve ignorance?
We'd are no
once the veil of ignorance is left dead,
why that we're going to be Christians
or Jews or Muslims or atheists or
agnostics or something else, right?
We don't, we don't know that.
Right?
So how should we think about the question
of whether it should be an established
religion?
Well,
and this is where his one of his,
his conceptual innovations comes in.
He says,
the way to think about it is from the
standpoint of the most adversely affected
person.
Cause you don't know who you're going
to be. Right? So for any principal,
if, if you could say, well,
if I was the most adversely affected
person by that principle and I would still
choose it,
then it starts to look like procedural
expression of the categorical imperative
because if the person most disadvantaged
by it would choose it over the going
alternatives, then presumably
everybody else would. Okay.
And so,
so this is a misunderstanding of
roles that people often get into.
He says
at one point,
if the standpoint of justice is the
standpoint of the least advantaged person,
but this is not a kind of
bleeding heart liberal point.
He's not saying the stand point of
justice is a standpoint of the least
advantage person because we should feel
sorry for the least advantaged person,
that poor bag lady and that rich Trump
isn't that disgusting to contemplate.
That's not his point.
It's a self interested point,
completely self interested point.
He's saying you figure out what you
would choose in this situation of turning
out to be the most disadvantaged person.
That is a stand point of justice.
Not because we feel badly for
the most disadvantaged person,
but because we want a universalized
about principle. Okay.
That's the point.
So it's not,
it's not that he's, as I said,
it's not a bleeding heart point.
It's a self interest point.
It's it's self interest in the
service of universalize ability.
It's to get people to pick a principle
that they would affirm no matter what.
Okay.
That's the sense in which roles
thinks of himself as a content.
Okay,
now let's come back to religious freedom.
Wow.
If we had an established church and
you turned out to be a member of the
established religion,
you would be completely happy.
But if we had an established church and
you'd turned out to be a nonbeliever or
believer in a different religion,
you wouldn't be happy. Right?
You'd be less happy,
at least then the person who turns out
to belong to the established religion.
That part's straightforward.
But that's not the interesting comparison.
It's not the illuminating comparison.
So Raul says,
think about it like this.
The question's whether or not to have an
established church established religion.
Right?
So think about the,
the person who is not a member
of the established religion
in a world in which there
is an established religion,
right?
Versus the believer in a world in
which there is no established religion.
Because if, if, if, if you
suppose you're an atheist, right?
And we have no established religion,
you're happy.
But if on the other hand are
the fundamentalist is unhappy.
Right?
But so for Rawls,
the relevant comparison is would you
rather be a fundamentalist in a regime
where there's no established religion
or
and nonbeliever in a regime where
there is an established religion.
Okay.
And his argument for this established
religion is that the believer in the
disestablishment regime has more religious
freedom than the nonbeliever and the
established machine.
Right.
To make this concrete fundamentalists
have more religious freedom in America
than non fundamentalists
have in Saudi Arabia.
Yeah. Well, Iran.
So the reason to prefer the reason to
prefer this establishment of religion is
that if you're trying to maximize the
religious freedom of the least advantaged
person,
it's you have to look at the least
advantage person in all of the possible
regimes of governing religion.
Right?
And so the defense of the establishment
clause of the u s he doesn't talk about
this example, but I'm, it's my
example, but it's his logic, right?
If you said the roles in defense of
the establishment clause of the u s
constitution, that's what it
would be. It's not, you know,
fundamentalist.
Often Christian fundamentalists often
criticize the establishment clause,
particularly in the way it's
been interpreted by the courts.
They say it's presented as neutral
among religions and it's not,
it's not neutral because it works.
You know,
people who think they shouldn't be an
established religion getting exactly what
they want, but we who think that should
be, don't get exactly what we want.
So it's not neutral. Correct.
That correct. It's not neutral.
And roles actually contributes to
confusion here because sometimes he talks
about his theory as as neutral.
It's not neutral.
And the, the, the requirement is
not that it should be neutral,
but rather that it should give the
most extensive religious freedom
okay.
To the person who's most disadvantaged
in either system. So as I said,
the key point is that the believer,
okay,
has more religious freedom.
If you have something like the
u s s establishment clause,
then the nonbeliever has,
when you have a fundamentalist
regime that's the claim.
And so you want to give the most
extensive system of religious freedom
compatible with a light system for all
right?
And the way you get compared with the
light system for all is to look at it from
the standpoint of the most
adversely affected personnel,
the least advantaged person in any case.
So that's the basic way in which
he reasons. And that's why these,
this sort of rather
empty sounding phrase here,
that is this first principle,
uh,
actually has more content than might
appear to be the PSI at first sight to be
the case. Right? So it's, it's, um,
the standpoint of justice is a standpoint
of the most disadvantaged person,
not because of being a bleeding heart,
but because you want a universalized
about principle and we,
it's just the cake cutting you giving
the knife to the right person is getting
the last slice.
You say,
pick the system that will give you the
most religious freedom when you just,
when you later discover
what your beliefs are,
right?
And that is the principle you
should affirm. And that is why I,
religious fundamentalists should choose
disestablish the establishment
clause of the u s okay.
Now somebody might come along with some
other principal and show that it does
better and then we'd have to go through
the process again. But, so that,
that's the basic structure
of Rawlsian reasoning.
If you lie about principles of Justice,
okay, we'll pause there
and pick up on Wednesday.